[Music]
grayson
you piano player bubba yeah
when it comes to the best baby gifts
would you say carrie underwood's baby
gift was maybe the best
[Music]
hands down and that is actually one of
his favorites is that piano it came
right on time in a time that was really
hard for me and just to watch him light
up when he was playing the piano was
just
too much
have you ever thought about doing a
collab with carrie and your son because
i would just be adorable
like that would be like a dream come
true just to watch her hold my baby
would just be enough for me and while
we're crossing our fingers for that duet
mickey did take the stage with another
superstar the one and only miley cyrus
for miley cyrus presents stand by you a
peacock concert event
[Music]
[Applause]
she is incredibly kind yeah and very
real
[Music]
she's awesome to sing with and mickey
should have no trouble scoring the rest
of her dream collabs now that her album
debut remember her name has officially
hit the airwaves
there's
literally a song for everyone
i hope people walk away feeling hopeful
it's a journey there's lessons you laugh
you'll cry
what kind of response do you get
specifically for women the responses i
get a lot of women just feel seen like
no matter who they are who they love
they feel seen and they feel like
somebody understands them and that was
my whole purpose so yeah it's really
cool to feel that